but first my thoughts at the end of day
28 America and shutdown now over the
past few weeks our fellow citizens have
learned a lot about the so called
experts you know the people who we're
told are the standouts the most learning
professionals in their fields now
talking about politics in the media and
in science well let's remember what we
were hearing out of New York this is
just a few weeks ago politicians who
made enormous ly expensive requests from
the federal government based on data
that turned out to be false all the
projections say you could have an apex
needing 140,000 beds and about 40,000
ventilators we're following the data and
the science and that's what the data and
the science says those claims were based
on the faulty models of the Imperial
College of London study and there were
profound implications trillions of
dollars spent based on the fear that
those numbers were at least in the
ballpark we were told that the American
hospital system was in danger of
collapsing if we didn't flatten that
curve well the numbers weren't even
close
behalf of downstate New York we're in a
position now where we're not going to
need the ventilators we're going to be
ok equipment wise unless things change
dramatically no one who is needed a
ventilator has not gotten a ventilator
no one who is needed a hospital bed has
been denied a hospital but our hospitals
were not overwhelmed and are not
overwhelmed at this hour that is great
news it's a hundred percent correct the
eye hme model from the University of
Washington has the latest numbers and
projections now right now there is ZERO
shortage of ICU beds and zero shortage
events the projected need for
ventilators on the peak day is fourteen
thousand four hundred and seven
nationally that's nationally for ICU
beds well guess what
the numbers just killed the estimates
originally and by the way another cost
of these lame panic inducing models it
looks like we really didn't need the USS
mercy or the USS comfort in New York or
Los Angeles Americans should be furious
about this of course the men the women
and these ships are doing their
patriotic duty
they're amazing the commander's amazing
but this is a lot of money that we're
spending on a response that was based
again on faulty numbers now long before
the government figured out that these
fancy covered 19 models were wrong my
own little team little band of medical
advisors and a few statisticians they're
a lot smarter than I am insisted that
they had also crunched the numbers and
this was weeks ago they were making
decisions the people in charge based on
what my team said were wildly incorrect
assumptions and ultimately incomplete
data so it was 18 days ago on March 24th
I press dr. pouchy on New York's Pacific
ventilator an ICU bed requests if the
numbers are not right then maybe that
affects the decision-making about when
the country can gradually get back to
business you're absolutely right Laura
and that's exactly right FEMA is working
closely with the state of New York to
try and figure out exactly what they'll
need at what time I mean if the totality
is 30,000 what do they need now next
week the week after but you're right
those kind of models do help inform us
well it was kind of an answer but non
answer I mean my question is if if my
guys knew the numbers were wrong they
did why didn't the experts know that the
numbers were wrong as well why didn't we
adjust our shutdown strategy given the
huge readjustment in for instance that
key number the mortality number well the
president today indicated that he did
suspect that Cuomo's requests were way
too high but he kicked into action
anyway fortunately we don't need just
like we didn't need as many ventilators
when they were asking in New York for
40,000 ventilators I had experts these
people I listened to that they said
you'll never need that many and they
were right well he was right
it didn't think about that was right and
now the blame game of course has begun
because over the weekend the New York
Times attempted to make the case that
dr. Anthony Fauci and others they were
urging the President to shut down the
country I guess earlier pouchy said this
to Jake Tapper you could logically say
that if you had a process that was
ongoing and you started mitigation
earlier you could have saved lives
obviously no one is going to deny that
if we had right from the very beginning
shut everything down it may have been a
little bit different but there was a lot
of pushback about shutting things down
back then he kind of clarified this at
the press common today but what was he
talking about there at the end of
February he himself was saying publicly
and presumably advising the president
that there wasn't all that much to worry
about watch should we be changing our
habits and if so how no right now at
this moment there is no need to change
anything if you're doing on a day-by-day
basis you've got to watch out because
although the risk is low now you don't
need to change anything you're doing
when you start to see communities spread
yeah this could change well based on
these projections that again we've gone
through week after week we're wrong
pouchy and others eventually did push
for a national shutdown and in places
like New York I've kamehame could make
the argument that that was necessary
there but now and you look at all these
other states because tax revenues aren't
coming in again beyond new york new york
is the case in and of itself here
numbers are so bad there but the states
want more federal bailout money
governor's Larry Hogan of Maryland
Andrew Cuomo of New York and a bunch of
others are teaming up to demand five
hundred billion dollars from the federal
government that's right half a trillion
dollars 11 zeroes which is where's that
money gonna come from
I guess we'll print
we'll borrow it will end up weakening
our country in the long run look for
huge tax increases down the road to pay
for all this which of course will
further hamper economic growth well not
that the media gives a darn they're too
busy trying to blame Trump for not
locking down the country fast enough
even though his medical advisors had not
yet suggested that he spent part of his
press conference today setting that
record straight
because we're getting fake news and I
like to have it corrected they're saying
what a great job we're doing and the
Mita these are the governors of
California Governor of New Jersey
governor of New York in New York
ventilators we're going to be a problem
we didn't think I'd have a problem beds
were gonna be a problem I mean I'm happy
about it the Javits Center which is
incredible is almost empty because they
don't need it that's good news not bad
news all they did was took some flips
and they just ran them for you and the
reason they did is to keep you honest
now I don't think that's gonna work it's
not gonna have any impact oh hey the
president is really frustrate a via Slee
the media spent on all this has been
outrageous all the while they ignore the
cost of course of the other costs that
are piling up here medical procedures
that people are putting off because
they're afraid
due to this crisis the cost to our
citizens mental health because of forced
isolation the cost of family harmony
children's well-being being kept out of
school and of course the cost to our
civil liberties during the Easter
weekend liberal mayors and governors
moved against people of faith in
disturbing ways in some places even
outdoor religious gatherings where
people remained in their cars were in
legal limbo and they hinge on the whims
of state and local officials Mayor Greg
Fischer of Louisville had his police
harassed churchgoers and dr2 who
actually dared to attend services again
in their cars so if you sit in your car
at a liquor store you're fine but not at
a church now a federal judge slapped him
with a temporary restraining order it
was blistering we're gonna get to that
in a moment but I say it's time
for Congress and for state legislators
to get back into session if they truly
believe these ongoing shutdowns beyond
New York beyond the hot spots are
necessary then it's time for them to
pass laws mandating them stop hiding
behind emergency declarations for a
virus that while devastating well
probably in the end according to the new
projections take fewer lives of working
Americans than heart disease or the flu
get back to work so the rest of us can
do the same Congress and those are my
thoughts at the end of day 28 America
and shut down